holy chiz crazy it's it's the amazing
thing about relations that we have I
don't think 6000 people who all have
such a huge amount of passion for our
projects and are the reason why we do
this and to come here and to like tease
them and show them a little bit it's so
fun and and also to just meet the rest
of the Marvel Universe it's like one of
the most amazing things ever and it's
been crazy it's been a crazy day so far
even though I've been shooting it it
doesn't feel like a spider-man movie to
me because with the costume all hanging
out and it feels like a sort of high
school movie but then to see it on that
scale and to see spider-man and to see
the vulture and all of that is just so
exciting and I'm so happy to share it
with the wonderful cast that we have and
I'm speechless I really am speechless
but everyone in the audience sort of was
like no wait and you can feel that
atmosphere in a room like that and and
to be able to make people experience
that and to be part of that processes is
is pretty special and wonderful this is
my first comic-con and it's the first
time obviously the first time I've
experienced this like level of of
superhero fandom and and I'm a superhero
fan myself so it's nice to be amongst
these people that share the same passion
and and it's it's nice to be here to see
so many people coming together to
celebrate this art which she puts just
what it is really and and it's a
pleasure it's a pleasure to see people
enjoying themselves in this in this
place this is awesome this is one of the
coolest things that I think I've ever
done in my entire life and I get to do
it with really cool people my cast is
like they're so nice they're so real
and so funny in real life and on screen
so it's just like to be able to share
this with them is the bomb and I'm just
very lucky and very very excited so the
best way the energy was just insane that
the fans were just loving everything
they were doing like more literally
great job I love the fans and I think
they're amazing and I was so nervous
walking in as soon as I walked up all
that went away cuz the fans are just so
medium yeah every was positive energy
everyone was so excited and it just got
to feel really good and I'm really proud
that I was screaming on the side I was
yelling oh hey guys oh hey guy we're
just gonna take you home it's like every
other interview we do together she's not
here he's funny when you be like this it
doesn't feel real because of the scale
of it and I see it put together and to
be like see your friends on screen it
was such a rewarding experience and also
like the reactions been amazing I know
it is just me today I was experiencing
it with everyone there it was we were
all in the back me and all the kids from
Spidey just looking at the screen from
the side just trying to see all this
stuff too because we haven't seen it
either so it was just his amazing got to
see tons of great stuff I just had a
stomach ache
it's really nerve-wracking to show
something while you're right in the
middle of making it but everyone sort of
freaked out so I take that as a good
sign it feels very safe you know you
walk out on that stage is the first time
I've ever you know have this experience
obviously and you just feel like this
wave of love and support and it's a
really great feeling
you